[Musique]
battus au groupe c'est une société qui
composait de trois entités batiweb qui
est sa marque médias historiques
existent depuis plus de 20 ans qui
informe les professionnels du bâtiment
et l'eau artisans et marchands online
[Musique]
on est un acteur dit de l'intermédiation
de mise en relation entre des
particuliers et des professionnels
[Musique]
et
e
on recrute un poste de responsable
acquisitions au sein de la direction
marketing
debaty web pour la marque hello artisans
on recherche un expert vraiment un
expert des solutions digitales un expert
de l'acquisition digital on a besoin
absolument de générer des leads rôle de
générer des demandes de devis
[Musique]
la capacité d' analyse compréhension de
l'environnement dans lequel dans lequel
on est une maîtrise du business model
c'est à dire le cpl travailler en équipe
l'équipe marketing ces huit personnes
quatre personnes qui sont dédiés à
l'acquisition mais c'est aussi des
équipes commerciales c'est des équipes
de qualification et de production avec
lesquels il faut partager en permanence
on recherche vraiment quelqu'un
d'expérimenté et qui vient de ceux de ce
milieu là entre 5 à 7 ans d'expérience
quelqu'un qui a déjà évidemment mis en
oeuvre des stratégies des campagnes
d'acquisition au lead ensuite on
recherche quelqu'un qui a une culture du
web une culture de la performance et qui
est orienté revenus
[Musique]